That,
I think that unfortunately extremism
is winning in the country and the vocal
minority just has a much larger
megaphone or microphone and the non vocal
majority.
I think most people do that.
But I don't think the people that do
that waste their time posting about it or
taking up the, you know,
just filling the narrative.
So it looks like there's only two
positions. That's a good point.
I would love to see some
return to moderation.
Just get extremism in any shape.
I feel very uncomfortable with people
who go to any length like that. Well
I think people are getting more and
more upset at it and I think as people
recognize that it's more and
more preposterous, they're
getting more and more,
there's more and more pushback
and resistance. You know,
it's really interesting with progressivism
is that people are getting in trouble
now for things that seem like there's,
there's something like
Martina Navratilova, uh,
just got a bunch of shit from people
calling her transphobic cause she was
saying that she didn't think that
biological male should be competing with
biological females and that there are
people who identify as transgender who
keep their penis and compete
as a man. And you know, her,
her position was like that or
compete as a woman rather ship.
And her position was like that.
Listen, that's not, that's not a woman.
That's a man.
And they have an advantage.
And she was citing all these instances
and so she got all this shit from people.
So then she said, I'm going to step
back and I'm going to research this.
So she stepped back and researched
it and then came back and said, no,
I've looked at all the data and
she probably came back harder.
She did come back harder and now
they're attacking her and calling her
transphobic.
Like let's say this is not trans phobia.
This is a real thing that you're going
to have to address when you're talking
about physical activities.
When someone identifies, look,
if you want to identify as a
woman or identify as a male,
I think we should all support people
doing whatever they want to do as long as
it's not hurting anybody.
Totally agree.
But when you're talking about competition
and you're talking about someone
identify,
I don't care if you identify as a Giraffe,
if you compete in an apple picking
competition with a Giraffe,
you're going to fucking lose.
You're not a giraffe stupid, right?
I mean this is just, I mean
this is an extreme version
of it, but that's nonsense.
That doesn't make any sense.
If you decide that you're a woman
and you want to enter into a fucking
weightlifting competition and you weight
220 pounds and you're beating all the
other women by like Oh
fucking insane numbers,
like there was a a few world champion
weightlifting winners that are women that
are actually biologically male, so they're
winning weightlifting competitions.
Just like, what the fuck are you
talking about? Like this is great.
This is not a matter of whether or not
someone should identify with something,
but it's,
you're talking about making it
fair for actual biological women.
Like there's a reason why women don't
compete with men is because physically
they're not as strong. So, and obviously
there's some exceptions or some weak men,
some strong women,
and there's some sort of a spectrum
and you find yourself somewhere on it.
But if you're allowing biological males
to compete with biological females and
just say, oh, he identifies
as a woman led him in, Yay,
we're all being very progressive. And
then you look at the results and you go,
well, he just broke all the world
records first time in the class.
And everybody's like, yes, amazing.
What a wonderful woman girl power. Like,
that's not girl power. You're,
you're, you're monkeying
with biology here. This is,
this is crazy. So what's the route?
What's the road out of that? Like,
what does that give you getting upset?
And it, the time, time, being timed,
you know, of these instances, um,
enough of these things happen.
Enough discussion where enough of the
actual reality of the facts and the data
are shoved in everyone's face enough that
the new generation comes to some sort
of a rational understanding about what
is and is not fair as opposed to where
people are now, where
they just, no matter what,
they're scared to not push
this progressive agenda.
And they're scared of the blow back of
Martina Navratilova who is an LBGT hero,
right? Yes. She's a fucking hero.
She was a lesbian woman who was
a world champion tennis player,
and now they're the left are
attacking her. So they're,
they're eating their own in a spectacular
fashion where you have these trans
people who don't want to look at reality
and then people that support the trans
people because they don't want
to be considered in any way,
shape or form anything other than
the most progressive of progressive.
And it's nonsense.